republican senator josh hawley is
blaming canceled culture
after getting dumped by his book
publisher simon and shuster ending a
book deal it had with the senator
they cited hawley's leading role in
challenging the election results
and they linked it to the riot on
capitol hill hawley responding by
calling it an attack on free speech and
even orwellian
dana you've got a book coming out let me
ask you don't these publishing companies
have the right
as private enterprises to publish
whoever they choose
yes but please don't cancel everything
will be okay i mean that's like
therapy for the nation no no no don't do
that
i am definitely not for canceling books
i'm not for burning books
um i think that yes they have the right
to do it and i think that a lot of
times this comes from within in terms of
employee revolt type of thing
but one of my favorite books from last
year was called american dirt
it was a novel that was written about a
migration from um
an illegal immigration from mexico into
the united states of america it got
cancelled because it wasn't written by
somebody who was latino
or hispanic enough for the woke crowd
but guess what happened that book ended
up selling lots of our copies
and had a huge run on the best seller
list because of all the controversy so
holly might just make out here in the
end
so jesse in fact holly is a yale law
school
graduate very familiar with the first
amendment but he brings it up and says
oh you know this is censorship this is
first amendment violation
that has nothing to do with a private
company deciding they don't want to do
business with them
well chim-min and shuster just published
a
boatload of hannity books so i don't
know how woke
simon and schuster all of a sudden is
they probably
it's all about the money they probably
just didn't think hawley was gonna sell
that many copies
and they figured you know why not just
like cut them down
and take a small loss in exchange for
some attaboys
from the libs in the publishing industry
they'll have to figure out with a bunch
of lawyers if he gets to keep
how much of his advance but dana's right
this will help book sales for holly
he'll get it published somewhere else
and then he can bill it as the book
that's too dangerous to be published
and he'll and he'll do a great number
but what he was doing challenging the
electors
the democrats challenged electors the
last three republican presidents
that were elected nancy pelosi
challenged electors so whatever he was
doing was
perfectly constitutional and just
representing his constituents
who had concerns about unfairness in the
election
katie more on cancel culture michelle
obama says she wants
these uh social media companies to push
harmful voices off of social platforms
what do you think of course she does
because she's not a person who's open to
tolerating different viewpoints and
having a better debate she just wants to
shun them which is
very dangerous for our democracy as the
left always says
but for simon and schuster to get josh
hawley off of their publishing list like
yeah
their private company they have the
right to do it but it's really pathetic
and juan you talked about the first
amendment being cited by josh hawley
without the first amendment simon
schuster doesn't exist
so this idea that they're now caving to
a woke mob because there's someone who
ironically
is publishing a book about cancel
culture and social media companies
claiming they're for all points of view
but not publishing this book is really
pathetic and it is goes against
everything they claim to stand for and
how they make their money
through the first amendment